le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
comme chaque année au moment de la
période des fêtes le département
réinvente le jardin de l'état du 13 au
21 décembre se dérouler la cinquième
édition de bonheur des enfants
avec pour thème cette année le cosmos
l'occasion pour les agents du
département de mettre en avant leur
savoir faire en créant une ambiance
unique au coeur de la ville où petits et
grands peuvent s'émerveiller
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines des drôles
d'animaux ont élu domicile au jardin de
l'état
ces créatures fantastiques assemblée à
l'occasion de la 5e édition de bonheur
des enfants sont l'oeuvre de la filière
embellissement du département
départementale a toujours été dotée
d'une filière embellissement le
département n'a pas de paysagiste en
fait donc c'est pour ça que cette
cellule est très important car on va
rester sourd l'entretien la gestion de
l'ensemble des sites donc culturelle et
historique sur tous les parcs pour cette
année les agents ont utilisé une
technique particulière pour le bonheur
des enfants
nous avons mis l'accent sur la mosaïque
culture donc amusé culture c'est
vraiment un savoir-faire que les agents
aux acquis pendant
en quelques mois en fait c'est une
structure en fer qui est comblée de
substrats donc différent selon les
plantes et ensuite nous plantent des
micros motte
donc ces petites plantes qui vont se
développer donc dans un ou deux mois
le dodo a aura vraiment sa forme
initiale ce qui est super dans la
moselle culture on peut tout faire tout
est réalisable en fait dès le 13
décembre le jardin de l'état a laissé
place à un tout autre lieu
un voyage onirique au coeur de la ville
avec une année riche sur le plan
économique un thème s'est imposé
naturellement le cosmos est une
particularité pour cette année les
paysages galactiques sont le fruit de
recyclage il faut savoir que 90 % de la
décoration de l'année dernière a été
recyclé que ce soit au niveau des
nichoirs au niveau des champignons on a
aussi des ont retrouvé des structures
qui ne servaient pas donc aujourd'hui on
peut dire que 60 % de toute la
décoration était fabriqué en interne et
90 % 2 06 p des valeurs partagées avec
l'artiste à l'origine de la scénographie
c'est vrai que l'artiste plasticienne
tatiana pas de chama nous apporte
beaucoup de technicité et nous apporte
aussi ses cités puisqu'elle est
travaille beaucoup avec des tissus
recyclés elle travaille beaucoup avec
des objets recyclés des matières
recyclées ce qui fait que on a fait
appel à elle pour que justement avec
l'inventaire des structures existantes
on puisse se l'approprier et remettre
dans l'univers du thème choisi une
invitation au voyage au coeur de la
ville où petits et grands sont invités
c'est la fin d'année et la famille
réunionnaise se rassemble non seulement
pour fêter dans la joie du plaisir de se
retrouver de partager avec les enfants
et c'est aussi l'occasion pour nous au
département de montrer les savoir faire
des agents
comment on récupère des vieux vieux
tissus et comment avec des artisans une
couturière
on peut en faire de belles fleurs
réaliser un arbre de noël à partir des
roses en papier fait par les agents oui
c'est vraiment la vitrine des
savoir-faire du conseil départemental
des classes défilent tout au long de la
journée pour profiter d'une sortie
originale
le concept a déjà ses fidèles pour
passer la journée au dehors la
multiplicité des activités
c'est vraiment très très bien organisée
donc voilà on est bien cadré on a un
plan au c ur var effet les enfants
adorent l'endroit et on peut voit là on
peut facilement passer la journée ça
s'ennuyer
c'est très proche des écoles on peut
venir à pied dont c'est vraiment pour
bénéfice de nombreuses activités
permanentes et temporaires sont disposés
dans le parc ferme géante carrousel
trampoline atelier bois de goyavier ou
encore patinoire pour cette classe de
cm2 la prochaine destination et l'espace
grimpe aux arbres
je viens de grimper un large avec une
corde comme un peu de l' escalade
j'avais jamais vu ça c'était une super
journée
on a fait plein d'activités génial on
s'est baigné c'était génial on a joué
les décorations du jardin de l'état
stimule l'imagination des enfants
chacun y allant de son interprétation à
l'allaiter ça fait beaucoup penser à
noël et le départ les quatre hectares du
jardin ont été découpée en huit zones
avec chacune une ambiance particulière
la scénographie préparé depuis le mois
de février a été pensé pour la journée
comme pour la nuit
une fois le jour tomber le jardin revêt
ses illuminations de noël afin de mieux
profiter des spectacles proposés chaque
soir pour bien démarrer la période des
fêtes de fin d'année après à noël en
famille nous souhaitons je souhaite en
mon nom personnel au nom de mes élus de
tous les agents du conseil départemental
de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année à toutes
les familles réunionnaises que nous
puissions avoir une année 2010 est dans
dans la paix avec l'éducation à la paix
l'éducation que nous devons continuer à
faire en sorte que le vivre ensemble
réunionnais perdure en gardant les
valeurs familiales parce que c'est vrai
que de bonnes fêtes en famille on n'a
rien inventé de mieux que la famille
[Musique]
au bonheur des enfants est devenu un
événement incontournable pour les
réunionnais pour cela le département a
investi de nombreux moyens matériels et
humains pour cette cinquième édition
plus de 150 personnes ont été mobilisées
soit plus de vingt corps de métier en
travaillant en équipe pendant quatre
mois afin de créer 400 éléments de décor
montée 25 structures et sans
installation lumineuse dans une optique
de développement durable
les agents du département ont fabriqué
60% de la décoration en interne et
recycler 90 % des décorations de
l'édition passée ce qui représente pas
moins de 600 mètres carrés de textile 18
tonnes de métal et neuf mille plants
pour plus d'informations sur les dates
de réouverture du jardin de l'état
rendez vous sur le site du département
au www.cglpl.fr
[Musique]
m